hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast challenges and new solutions
for isolating exosomes other cellular
obstacles and vesicular rnase I am
Rachel Brown of lab roots now be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab roots and
sponsored by qiagen I know you will all
agree that the pursuit of any biological
research begins with a sample it can be
blood or tissue or cell as you all know
qiagen offers you innovative solutions
that cover every single step along this
journey not just technologies but
bridges from samples to insights for
more information please visit qiagen com
we have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of your
presentation window or submit your
problems through the Korean a Q&A button
lower left I would now like to introduce
today's speaker dr. Martin schlumberger
dr. schlumberger has a PhD in chemistry
and more than 20 years of experience
working in genetics and molecular
biology he did his postdoc torial
fellowship at the institute of
neurodegenerative diseases at UCSF he
has been at qiagen for over 13 years
developing new strategies and products
both manual and automated to isolate
nucleic acids from a wide variety of
samples and including extracellular RNA
and mi RNA from serum plasma exosome
RNA as well as intact exomes and other
extracellular vesicles
he started as a research scientist and
is currently an associate director came
sample Technology Development Group I
will now turn it over to dr.
Schneeberger for his presentation hi
everybody thanks for listening in and
for your interest in this topic and also
for left roots for inviting us we seem
to have some network problems actually
so I've I will ask for to have two
slides advanced and I hope there won't
be any other issues so with that I go on
to the first slide this is just a visual
impression of what we are talking about
so on the left hand is shown a scanning
electron micrograph that shows a clear
plastic my brain cancer cell and you can
see it's has these protrusions and
budding vesicles all over the surface so
this is just an example of how for too
many tumor cells basically produce these
extracellular vesicles in really large
amounts and on the right hand side you
see a transmission electron micrograph
showing to XM to multi what is called
multivesicular bodies this is part of
the endosomal pathway where basically
vesicles pinch off from the endosomal
membrane and so that are they are
generated intra endosomal vesicles that
contain cytoplasmic material this is
what the two arrows show like and then
these multivesicular bodies can fuse
with the plasma membrane and thereby
release their vesicular content into the
surrounding media and that is also shown
on the next slide in a schematic I think
so this is slide 3 now and it's
basically shows again in the in the
lower panel here the schematic drawing
of the multivesicular bodies how they
originated by endocytosis then the intra
endosomal vesicles are formed and then
finally released when the endosome fuses
with the plasma membrane and this is the
canonical pathway for what most people
call an exorcist there is some
unfortunately some discrepancy and how
the definitions are being used but most
people define exosomes why are these
pathways and exercise are usually in the
size range of about 30 to 100 or maybe
150 nanometer again depends on who you
are talking to and then extracellular
vesicles can also pinch off directly
from the plasma membrane membrane this
is shown in the second illustration
that's right behind the other one or on
top of it and basically narrated that
way are usually a bit larger than what I
just said around 200 or 150 to 300
nanometers typically and these are often
referred to as microvesicles but like I
already said the definitions overlap and
some people use the terms
interchangeably even so why are we
interested in looking at the content of
those vesicles the reason is this you
can as you have seen in the first slide
for example cancer cells are producing
lots of these vesicles and so the what
has been shown is that they actually
contain a snapshot of what's going on in
the tumor cell and so we can use that
information and that is shown on slide 4
we can use for example not just
exosome the RNA but also other
accessible content of course I'm going
to be speaking mostly about RNA but
obviously protein and other biomolecules
are also of interest so basically these
vesicles are found in all kinds of body
fluids mainly blood urine but also CSF
saliva and died don't no tears breast
milk ascites synovial fluid pretty much
anything you can think of and those X's
owns like I already indicated contain
RNA and what is nice about it the
vesicular membrane actually protect
these RNAs from rnases that are present
in bio fluids especially plasma is full
of RNAs and any naked RNA is basically
completely degraded within seconds and
then what is inside the vesicles is safe
and stable as i'm going to show and that
RNA actually provides a snapshot of the
transcriptomes of the cells where they
come from that could be to morse
metastasis and also other kinds of
diseases like I don't know liver
cirrhosis or toxicity all kinds of cells
basically are producing these vesicles
and disease or stressed cells typically
tend to produce even more which is nice
if you want to get to use this for
figuring out what is happening in the
organism actually or what is going wrong
and there are actually two ways you can
use this especially it is regard to a
cancer you can obviously profile RNA
levels and use that expression profile
it's like a fingerprint of what is going
on also in for example two more cell and
the other thing that you can also use
the RNA or also DNA four
is to look for disease specific
mutations again that's relevant
particularly for cancer where we can
look for people have detected chaos
b-raf mutations and all that in the RNA
that is basically released into the
bloodstream next slide so this from this
I think it's pretty clear why people are
so interested in those vesicles and
characterization of the vesicular
content so with respect to RNA
specifically there are some important
considerations that you have to have in
mind when you start doing experiments
like that and I think pretty much the
most important is the background from
cellular RNA obviously blood contains
lots of blood cells and the RNA content
in cells is several orders of magnitude
higher than what is found in vesicles
mainly or if only by their much larger
size so you have to be very careful to
exclude any remaining cells from your
starting sample beat plasma theorem or
saliva because if you don't do it you
will essentially have cellular RNA
blanking out your extracellular signal
that's because it's more abundant and in
our particles also but most people
recommend is to do an upfront
centrifugation or filtration step in
addition to what is usually done to
generate plasma to make sure there is
really no cellular fragments or ercoupe
tajuk bodies and thrombus I track mins
remaining another consideration is a
specificity can be because there is I
just said that cell-free RNA is usually
degraded when it's in plasma because of
the rnases
but there is at least a population of
cell-free micro RNA that is associated
proteins and thereby protected from
rnases so you do have a certain
population of non vesicular cell-free
RNA and depending on what method you use
this is most often most methods will not
distinguish between these two
populations like if you do I'll try
centrifugation to pellet extracellular
vesicles you will also pellet large
approaching complexes to some degree and
what we did the protocol be designed
actually is specific for the vesicle and
basic ruler content and so this allows
people to distinguish what is in
vesicles and what not and I guess the
question is still open in which areas
this is especially useful but what you
can imagine is cell-free RNA that is not
in vesicles is probably mainly released
when cells die apoptosis or necrosis and
then the active risk complex is
basically released and they go to
protein that is associated with micro
RNAs protects them from rnases and on
the other hand the production of
vesicles is an active process and so you
could easily imagine that depending on
what phenotype or disease you're looking
at your it may lead to generation of
free RNA by necrosis or apoptosis or
maybe some other phenotype or disease
will mainly result in production of
vesicles so you if you have seen the
picture of the glioblastoma cell in the
beginning you can easily imagine that in
case of cancer a lot of what is released
will be in vesicles RNA purity is
obviously also of concern and so here
it's mainly important to have
recorded produce is really high quality
RNA and also intact intact RNA and i
will show you some data on how intake
the RNA is that we can get from vesicles
and finally a consideration is also how
much sample can you actually process how
much simple you have available obviously
and how much you can process and so the
issue is that many transcripts are
really present at very low copy numbers
in the cell-free fraction and that's
especially true for messenger RNAs
microRNAs are usually present at higher
copy numbers and messenger RNA is not so
much so far especially if you're looking
at messenger RNAs and mutations for
example you want to process large
volumes of sample to get the required
sensitivity and so what I'm showing the
method is able to deal with up to 4 ml
of serum or plasma and with that on the
next slide is just shows how the basic
how the method works basically this is a
flowchart like I already mentioned we
after we generate the plasma by
centrifugation and we employ an extra
filtration step to eliminate cell
fragments apoptotic bodies and alike we
recommend to use a 0 point 8 micrometer
filter for that because we think that is
the right cut off to make sure that
there are no cell fragments in principle
one can also use centrifugation and to
change the conditions or the filter pore
size a bit if the interest is mainly
towards smaller sized vesicles you can
spin it a bit harder beforehand or use a
lock the smaller pore size the filtered
plasma is then mixed with the binding
buffer applied to a spin column and here
we use the membrane that retains all the
vesicles that are present in the sample
so we we didn't really think it would be
useful to go after particular sub
fractions of vesicles at this point
especially considering that there is a
large there's no agreement really in the
field which from which population or sub
fraction of the vesicles is really the
most important depending on what people
are working on and what methods they use
everybody prefers a different sub
fraction and so this method will give
you all for the entire vesicle
population everything that is smaller
than the filter pore size that you
employ then we watch and we actually
when we go for RNA we do a combined life
is in delusion step and then so we take
that lysate and apply it to an RNA
column to isolate the RNA directly so we
don't go we don't isolate vesicles first
we bind them to the membrane and then
destroy them in the illusion process
this is what we call the XOR and easy
kid that is also mentioned in the title
they also worked on a protocol to I to
release intact vesicles this is
basically in the middle column in the
lowest panel basis life vesicles so at
this point we have a different version
of the same project whole order also the
kit where you can use an aqueous buffer
to release intact vesicles and then
those vesicles can be used for physical
characterization sizing or also for
biological experiments when you
basically you can isolate vesicles and
then apply them to for example cultured
cells or even to animals and see what
changes or what phenotype they they
cause in the target cells so that's like
I said a different different product
that we are just releasing on the next
slide
this is basically an example of how the
intact released vesicles are look like
this is a scanning electron micrograph
so what you can see is on the right part
is the eluate with intact vesicles that
we get from the column the size bar that
is in the blank space underneath the
image this is barely recognizable I'm
afraid but the size file you can just
barely see there is 200 200 nanometers
this is in agreement with what is
expected from the larger vesicles and
then you also see a lot of smaller
vesicles that are in the size range of
30 to 100 nanometers roughly and on the
left panels you can see for comparison
this is vesicles prepared by
ultracentrifugation we can also see some
vesicles just similar to what we see in
the XO easier Luet we also see a lot of
smaller particulate matter in the
background which we think is probably
large approaching complexes that are
co-piloting in the ultra centrifugation
protocol and we get less of that in our
method because the membrane basically
selects for the vesicles next slide we
are in flight eight now and this
basically is supposed to show that we
get nicely linear recovery of RNA
dependent on how much sample input
volume will we use here we are starting
at five hundred microliters and up to 4
ml you can see that to CT values for a
number of different transcripts that
were analyzed here decrease in a linear
fashion about roughly one CT value of
one cycle for each doubling of the
sample volume as expected so there is a
few messenger RNAs here like brf and
hprt and three Mike to micro RNAs let 7a
and
16 and ribosomal RNA that we also detect
in the vesicles and so far email is the
nominal binding capacity of the column
for serum and plasma and you can see if
we apply larger volumes to the column
the CT values do not improve much any
further and may actually decline a bit
but after that it's perfectly linear
next slide slide 9 now so the question
is what does the RNA actually look like
and so here's a representative
electropherogram from the bioanalyzer
and we comparing here x 0 rgz el Oso and
compared to RNA isolated from ultra
centrifugation pellet in this case from
two milliliter of plasma and so what you
can see most of the RNA is actually
pretty small around 100 base pairs or
less there is some larger RNA but not
terribly much so it looks very very
different from what you isolate from
cells and for most people electro for
ferrochrome pattern like this indicates
that it's really just degraded RNA and
in fact that's not really the case as I
can show you in the next couple of
slides so the next slide basically this
is still the bioanalyzer and what we did
here is we took the we fractionated the
RNA we isolate from the vesicle into a
small and large RNA fraction by
modifying the ethanol used for the
binding step and so you can see on the
left side the small RNA fraction you see
again that relatively large peak of
small RNA this is micro RNA but also
other stuff tRNA and some other small
non-coding RNAs and on the right side
you see the large RNA fraction and you
can even still see some ribosomal pants
they're not nearly as prominent as in
cellular RNA by they're still there
and some other large RNA and from the
ribosomal bands I think this is the
first indication that the RNA is
actually not really degraded because we
don't see the ribosomal been smearing
towards smaller sizes so we looked at
some messenger RNAs whether they are
recovered intact from the vesicles or
not or how intact they are and we did
that by pcr this is shown on the next
slide slide 11 so for this experiment we
basically isolated RNA again from the
extracellular vesicles then we prepared
cdna using two different methods in one
case we used random hexamers for cdna
synthesis priming and in the other case
we used only oligo dt so if the RNA is
degraded the the further away your PCR
implicant is from the poly a tail they
hired or the lower the chances are that
the cdna actually extends that far
because of strand breaks and what we
would see then is that the CP values are
higher than they are with the random
priming strategy and as you can see in
this example the CT values are all
pretty much the same no matter whether
we use oligo dt or random hexamers even
as far out as five kilo bases from the
poly a tails in case of decay Russ
amplicon so this indicates even 5k up to
5 kb out the RNA there is no sign of any
degradation which is kind of on first
glance it's pretty surprising if you
consider how the electropherograms look
like on second thought I guess this is
illustrates what I said previously that
when the RNA is inside the vesicles it's
really nicely protected from everything
that is outside
so this is like a little treasure vault
that keeps your RNA safe and obviously
this makes it even more useful for
basically useless biomarkers on the next
slide what we looking at here we are
comparing the rnav isolate from the
vesicles from diffraction that binds to
our membrane and the fraction that does
not bind to our membrane so we took the
flow through the column flow through
from the binding step and we isolated
RNA from that column flows through and
as well as from the fraction that is
retained on the membrane and then we did
a couple of or a number of qpcr essays
first of all the lighter shade diamonds
are four different micro RNAs and for
this analysis we looked at micro RNAs
that were previously described in a
paper that is referenced here below the
graph by a royal it I'll they did some
profiling of micrornas that are in
vesicles or not in vesicles in plasma
and we choose to that according to that
study are primarily outside of Mexicans
mere 16 and Mia 92a and two other micro
RNAs that we're reported to be made
mainly inside vesicles let's 7a and two
mil there is a typo here it should be
mil 142 3p sorry for that and when you
compare the CT values you can see sure
enough the blue and red ones near 60 10
mil 92a we get similar or even slightly
lower CT values when we analyze the flow
through indicating that a large part of
this is actually not in vesicles and not
retained by our membrane and then if you
look at the LED 7a and mill 42 signals
the mirror 42 is actually underneath
the mere 16 so it's not really well
visible in the left column but you can
easily see that the CP values are much
higher in the flow-through indicating
that most of that is in vesicles and
retained on the membrane now the
remaining data points are for messenger
RNA so we have BRF k rats hprt one a
ribosomal protein and get the h and we
all detect those some of them just
barely but we can detect them in the
vesicular fraction but we do not detect
pretty much anything at all in the
flow-through indicating that everything
is retained and presumably all in with
in vesicles and this actually makes
sense because in contrast to the micro
RNAs that can be protected by a protein
like a go to it's much more difficult I
don't think there is a protein really
large enough to fully protect a long
messenger RNA TV micro RNAs are
protected by a co2 and I think that's
what is reflected here and but it also
shows is that the vesicles are retained
very efficiently on the membrane because
if we would bind only eighty percent or
something like that then we would see
then we would still see stuff in the
flow-through it's only about three
cycles difference but as you can see the
difference is much larger for the
messenger RNAs so we have a really good
binding efficiency on the membrane and
so you may ask how do we know that this
what is retained on the membrane is
really inside vesicles then not retained
by for other reasons and to actually
demonstrate it that is shown on the next
slide so we are on slide 13 now if we
did an rnase protection sa basically we
followed the protocol we bind the
vesicles to the membrane and then we
apply to them to the vesicles while they
are still bound to the color membrane
and for the rightmost group of columns
we did not add anything and for the
second group from the left we edit only
RNAs and you can see that the signal
doesn't change terribly much so even so
we add RNA to to whatever is bound on
the membrane the rnase is not able to
degrade the RNA only if we add tritone
as well this is the group of columns to
the left when we add rnase together with
stretch and you can see that the RNA is
pretty much entirely gone destroyed by
the RNAs and so the tritone indicates
that this is a membrane that protects
the RNA from from the RNAs or vesicular
membrane and if we add Triton alone we
do see some degradation this is
presumably due to some RNAs that is
still present on the membrane that has
been carried over from from the plasma
center at this point so I think this
shows very nicely that the membrane rnav
isolate from the membrane is protected
by a vesicular membrane on the next
slide this is basically what i said
previously this is regarding sensitivity
here we looked at how much messenger RNA
can be actually detect in the self
reflection from plasma and what we used
here is what we call a PCR array this is
also a product provided by kyochon
obviously that has 96 or 384 different
messenger RNAs in this case it's a
96-well array so we have not actually
eighty four different messenger RNAs and
a bunch of controls all the essays are
pre
a raid on a plate and we only ate the
sample and the master mix to that and
then we can basically profile that set
of messenger RNAs in this case it was a
set of known oncogenes and we actually
included a pre amplification step to
make sure we get enough material for a
96-well and what you can see or what the
diagram is illustrating is when we start
with 200 microliters of plasma this is
the lowest box in that box plot from 200
microliters even with the pre
amplification we detect only about half
of the messenger RNAs raid on that plate
and when we go to from 200 microliters
to 12 and 4 ml we detect progressively
more of these transcripts and at for MLB
basically detects almost all of them so
this shows I think pretty nicely the
benefit of using a larger volume of
sample this is like I said especially
true for messenger RNAs because they are
not as abundant in the cell-free
fraction as the micro RNAs are for
micrornas on the next slide slide 15 I
have some some data this is also a
similar pci array now we have essays for
micro RNAs on the plate and we profiled
again the fraction that is isolated by
the XOR an easy project oil by the
column and what is not retained on the
column they flow through this entry
compared to CT values so on the x-axis
is basically the abundance of the micro
RNAs so to the right is the most
abundant to the left the least abundant
and on the y-axis we show the
distribution between vesicles and not in
vesicles so what is on the bottom is
largely not in vesicles and what is on
is mainly with in vesicles and marked in
color are again the same for micrornas
that we picked from the literature and
showed before on the previous or one of
the previous slides and so mere 92a and
mere 16 are again in diffraction that is
largely outside vesicles and me r 142
and let 7a are mainly inside vesicles
and what is also noteworthy we also have
here on in the lower right corner we
have miller for 451 which is a marker of
a retro site so from blood cells and so
it's very abundant in blood cells and
therefore also very abundant in plasma
and it's largely outside of vesicles
which I think basically reflects that it
this is there because of blood cell
lysis maybe during blood collection or
extraction finally on the next slide I
have an example for mutation detection
here plasma was isolated from a
colorectal cancer patient carrying a que
res mutation and what you and the
isolated RNA was subjected to targeted
RNA sequencing and what you can see is
we are able to detect the tumorigenic
mutation in plasma in the cell-free
portion in actually in this case about
ten percent of all reads carried the
mutant mutant signature this is also
reflecting that tumor cells produce a
lot of these vesicles so that summarizes
the first part of my talk conclusions we
have a protocol that extracts really
high-quality RNA from extracellular
vesicles the vesicles contain small and
large RNAs and the large RNA sacks
surprisingly intact still all of the RNA
pretty much all of the cell free
messenger RNA is in vesicles various
from the of the micro RNA we have two
distinct populations inside and outside
of vesicles and being by being able to
separate these two populations of micro
RNAs this may give us a better more
power in analyzing specific questions
and finally the vesicles we can detect
the expression of two more markers and
also mutations somatic mutations that
are only present in it two more for the
remaining few slides this is i will just
basically reflect on some questions that
we've been asked a lot and that we did
some follow-up experiments on basically
so the first what we often people are
interested to isolate exosomes or
exothermic RNA also from cell culture
supernatant basically cultured cells
obviously also produce these vesicles
and these vesicles produced by cell
culture can be used to answer a lot of
questions they have biological questions
they have also been used in some cases
even for therapeutic purposes to deliver
some cargo to other cells those are
looking at the stability of the vesicles
and large lastly the influence of sample
handling so next slide we're in slide 19
now this is showing that the protocol
works for cell culture medium here we
test it's different volumes of
psychiatry medium from 4 ml up to 32 ml
this is mcf-7 cells that they are
calculated for 48 hours either in
serum-free or vesicle free medium so
obviously since normal cell culture
medium contains fetal calf serum
or something similar you will have to
make sure that you either that or
because the fetal calf serum just like
human serum contains these vesicles you
have to make sure that you do not
introduce this into your culture because
otherwise you will have a mixed
population of vesicles from from the cow
and from yourself so there are two ways
to do that either you cultivate the
cells without serum or you use fetal
calcium that has been depleted of
vesicles you can bite it or prepare
yourself and what you can see the
protocol obviously works for both and we
get a linear recovery of RNA from these
cells in this case I think this is pita
acting that we monitored here beta
action messenger RNA you can see we get
fairly decent CT values and it's the CT
values decline linear linearly with the
input volume so in this case up to 32 ml
can be processed we obviously it will
depend very strongly on on what type of
cell you use and the culture conditions
so this is only an example if you don't
know yet beforehand we recommend to use
not more than 16 ml and I should also
say that at 32 ml we actually add 4
Callum loading steps for the binding I
have some trouble with my connection
right now I can't see my presentation
let's see just
okay alright so we can also on the next
slide slide 19 we looked at how well
protected is the RNA inside their
vesicles so what we did here is we did
we did the subjective of a week
generated plasma we took one aliquot
that we processed directly using the xor
an easy protocol and we took additional
Alec words that we froze and then
thought once or we actually did five
freeze and thaw cycles also and then we
also did as a negative control we took
one aliquot where we added SDS to
destroy all vesicles actually I'm sorry
this is cell culture medium not plasma
in this case but still we did I don't
know either process the psychiatrist
supernatant fresh or one or five crystal
freeze-thaw cycles isolated the RNA and
analyzed it and as you can see the
identical CT values in all cases so
indicating that the vesicles survived
the freeze and thaw cycles and in
contrast if we add the detergent to
destroy vesicles the RNA is basically
gone so next slide this is slide 21 now
this is actually done by a field test
customer who in this case the customer
isolated vesicles produced by hek293t
cells isolated the vesicles using XO
easy so the protocol for intact vesicles
he did an additional buffer change and
concentrating step by ultrafiltration
over using a 100 kilo dalton membrane
then later the isolated vesicles using
fluorescent lipid and finally removed
the excess unincorporated
using size exclusion and what you can
see the lower button labeled basic is
red and incubated with the target cells
again 293t cells a fresh culture for one
hour and what you can see the left is a
negative control Jesus died without
vesicles there is no uptake on the
bottom is nuclear staining this duppy
and on the right we have we can see the
uptake of dye into the cells so the
vesicles that we isolate are actually
function are not being taken up by self
for the last part that will try to go
over just briefly because you're
actually sort of time already here we
showed out the handling effects your
results on this light we have different
blood collection tubes and we also have
plasma in theorem in comparison and what
you can see first of all on first glance
you see no matter what blood collection
tube you use job is or we always get
some results we have a spike in control
here this is the gray the gray diamonds
that are about CT value of 22 and you
can see the CT value is very similar in
all cases which is indicating that we
isolate and amplify this spike in
control dissimilar efficiency in all
cases the only thing that we not
recommend this is the second column here
is heparin because heparin is difficult
to remove and is strong and inhibitor of
enzymatic reactions and what you also
see if you look at different transcripts
that we do have some variability
depending on what to be us and so the
message here is you shouldn't you can
use all these tubes except for heparin
but you shouldn't switch within a study
so if you do comparison between samples
it you should always use the same type
of blood collection tube next slide we
looked at this is slide 23 we look what
what happens if there is a delay between
blood collection and generation of the
plasma
and what you can see is we looked at a
range of different transcripts at
directly after blood collection and then
after one day at room temperature and
after three day of room temperature and
we then we compared the CT values we
took the Delta eg between day 1 and day
0 and day 3 and a zero for the bowel
infection the vesicular RNAs and the
flow through the non-basic real rnase so
the blue bars are the vesicular RNAs you
can see there is an increase after one
day about one cycle so indicated we have
two times as much vesicular RNA and
after three days up to eight times as
much and so what is important to keep in
mind this is obviously this is vesicles
that are produced by the blood cells
during the storage and what that means
most people are interested in vesicles
that come not from blood cells but from
elsewhere two more for example and so if
you have your blood staining around
blood cells keep producing best because
this will dilute out your message that
comes from elsewhere so that's why it's
important to avoid it and and the red
bar showed you flow through the
non-basic RNA you can see an increase
after day one and then a strong decrease
after three days what we think is
happening is that some of the cells die
after blood collection released RNA into
the plasma and then that is degraded
slowly over time depending like I said
the microRNAs are protected by proteins
probably and survived for a while and
then they eventually degraded I think we
can skip slide 24 for the sake of time
and goes directly to slide 25 this is
the final data slide I was just showing
here like I mentioned before we
recommend to do a filtration or
centrifugation to get rid of blood cells
remaining blood cells and cell fragments
from plasma and also thrombocytes or
whatever may still in debt
and in this experiment we basically
analyzed the effect of different
variations of that filtration or
centrifugation step first of all the red
bars you can see in the graph on the
left the red bars is plasma that is
generated by standard project oil doing
only five minutes 1903 centrifugation
and when you compared it to plasma that
was subjected to an additional three
thousand cheese centrifugation or
filtration on a point eight micrometer
filter this is the last the dark purple
bar I'm you can see that there is like a
three at least three or four cycle
difference so that three or four cycles
that means basically tenfold difference
so ninety percent of the RNA that you
see in the normal plasma is removed by
the point eight micrometer filter so
ninety percent is in fragments or
vesicles that are larger than probably
cell fragments that are larger than
eight hundred micrometers so this is
basically not what people are interested
in usually this is a Lego set apoptotic
fragments and alike and then as that we
recommend eight hundred micrometers
nanometers or three thousand cheese
centrifugation and you can see for all
for transcripts that we tested here the
bars this is the light blue and the dark
purple are very similar so these two
conditions gave roughly the same results
in our hand best when do a centrifuge at
16,000 g for 15 minutes you can see that
we lose some some of the RNA indicating
that we get rid of some of the larger
vesicles already interest yes and then
we also for when we combine 3,000 g and
800 micro 800 nanometers we lose a
little bit more this is the dark blue
bar here in the middle so basically I
guess both protocols together or both
treatments together remove a bit more
than each one alone even so they gave
similar results each by themselves and
then just for curiosity we also applied
smaller pore size fit as 200 nanometers
and 100 nanometers decided two remaining
bars and you can see that this further
resides in the further decrease in the
RNA levels that we see what I find
interesting here is that for the too
large a transcript gap th or long
transcripts gap th and 18s ribosomal RNA
that decrease is a lot more pronounced
than in case of the two micron is led 7a
and mere 16 and that indicates so that
at the very least the RNAs are not
evenly distributed over there vesicles
and it also hints at the long rnase
being present in longer a larger
vesicles mainly or more enriched in the
larger base because in my crown is more
enriched in the smaller vesicle and we
also looked at from the same experiment
we also did one aliquot very isolated in
txt vesicles and with this physical
characterization by nano site which
analyzes particles by microscopic
observation and brownian motion analysis
of Brownian motion and so you can see
decides the average size of the vesicles
that we get is about 160 nanometers
roughly and that doesn't change much
with any of these treatments except one
when we get to a 100 nanometer pore size
the vesicle diameter drops and similar
for the particle concentration only the
100 nanometer size pore size gives a
decrease substantial decrease so again
that also means that what is happening
to the RNA is different than what we see
on the vesicles and again indicates that
probably not all vesicles contain RNA so
conclusion we can eyes off the second
part so we can isolate exosomes and Isis
exosome and RNA also from cell culture
supernatant the vesicles are very stable
through several freeze-thaw cycles and
sample handling can severely affect your
results choice of blood collection tube
a delay in processing of the blood and
also that the centrifugation of
filtration you're doing is essential to
remove the background of cellular RNA
but also affect depending on what
conditions you use can affect a
representation of different classes of
vesicles and RNA and the RNA is not
evenly distributed obviously and then
acknowledgments so there are several
people at kyochon obviously who
contributed and then I should say that
the entire project or and also the
product was developed in cooperation
with exosome diagnostics and the data
and uptake vesicular uptake into cells
was provided by KC McCrea at Mass
General thank you for your attention
thank you for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session I would
like to remind our audience how to
submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can and
our first question is file analyzer
trace shows an increased amount of small
RNAs and presumably the micro RNA range
compared to the XO kit samples so how do
you account for this abundance of the
small RNAs given the highly variable en
images okay so there can you repeat the
question but there was the difference
was between which fractions or which
preparation I didn't
rnas increasingly the micro RNA range
compared to XO easy kit samples how do
you count for this abundance of small
RNA is given the highly variable p.m.
images I don't get the question that I'm
afraid so if we're comparing the XO easy
to what we compare I don't think I had
some I had any data I liked it I'm just
trying to figure out which is that
relating to his particular slide I'm you
can ask the person who submitted the
question Kira fries and so we'll come
back to that how about maybe I can also
answer that by email later if necessary
okay perfect and so the next question is
what is the maximum volume of samples
that can be used with the kids for cell
culture super time yeah like I said in
that example on that was in the
presentation I think slide 19 we have
tried up to 32 ml successfully which is
for binding steps if for more than four
binding steps i think the project koala
gets very tedious and i think it depends
also on what cell type you use some site
tax produce really insane amounts of
reticles in there the binding capacity
will probably be reached a bit earlier
this where mcf-7 cells and so this is
just an example i don't think it's
possible to really give an absolute
number here in that case okay great so
our next question is what is the
expected RNA yield yeah in terms of RNA
yields obviously the amount of cell-free
RNA is pretty low from plasma serum or
plasma we usually get about around 10
nanogram of RNA in total from
like 2 ml of plasma or so this is
measured by the bioanalyzer the amount
of RNA you get is if you have if you
really exclude all the cells is too low
to be measured by for example the
nanodrop or something so the nanodrop
may still give a signal from some
impurities but from RNA it's not
possible you have to use either estimate
by bioanalyzer or use something like
rival green fluorescent sa to detect the
nucleic acid from from the vesicles okay
great so our next question is how much
plasma or serum would you recommend
isolate from in order to have enough RNA
to perform next small RNA
next-generation sequencing successfully
yeah so what I showed in my presentation
obviously those were examples mainly for
pcr for pcr i can say that for 200
microliters we can detect most micrornas
that are actually there and form
messenger RNA of which use a lot more
like i showed for next-generation
sequencing you basically I would have to
say it really depends on your protocol
that you're using you will need some
kind of pre amplification step to
generate enough material for the library
and you i would say i would probably
recommend to use as much as you can and
really try to figure out what
amplification method gives you good
results we actually kyochon we just
released recently a single cell library
preparation kids that we tested or we
still testing for analysis of long rnase
from serum and plasma and that looks
pretty good or pretty promising but it
really depends on what method you
using so it should be enough but you
need some amplification that is powerful
enough it should be enough to give a
good representation i should say 200
microliters for micro RNA and 124 ml for
messenger okay we have time for one last
question the question is the use of
carrier RNA improve yield yeah like I
have shown you how the linearity of the
recovery and we do not justify this the
recovery that we do see without carrier
is pretty much perfect so there is no
indication that we get lower recoveries
when the not volume or the amount of
sample declines so that's the first
indication that is really not necessary
and also when we actually add carrier we
do not really see any improvement as far
as we tested so from my experience for
RNA at least in general I think the
carrier helps in precipitation based
protocols but for spin column based
protocols like are an easy or whatever
it doesn't seem to be required I'm
actually at sometimes I'm really
surprised how far down it remains linear
or basically as 5000's we can detect the
RNA by pcr okay great I would like to
thank our sponsors teijin and dr.
schlumberger for making today's
educational web class possible today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through november 2016 15 you
will receive an email from lab roots
alerting you when this webcast will be
available for replay we invite you to
forward that announcement to all of your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event see you next time goodbye